the vanishing rainforests of coastal
Brazil are home to an endangered primate
the golden lion tamarin this family is
among the fewer than 1500 tamarins
estimated to be left in the wild a
father a mother and their offspring they
spend much of the day on the move
combing their home range in search of
food favorites include small fruits
insects even an occasional lizard or fri
fiery lion like mains and tiny delicate
features make them look like designer
animals but tamarins are well adapted to
the forest long fingers and claw-like
nails allow them to steer deep into
nooks and crannies for food their vision
is first-rate to camouflage insects can
be hard to spot but tamarins often find
them easy prey insects are also
nutritious supplying the animal protein
needed and a healthy tamarind diet
sister and brother are playing with an
insect when Father sounds the danger
alarm an ocelot is on the prowl
with a fast efficient killer around
everybody heads for the trees it's an
easy escape the greatest threat to the
golden lion tamarin is people not
predators
great strides have been made in this
animals conservation but without more
sound management these coastal
rainforests and with them the golden
lion tamarins may disappear forever
Oh